foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
welcome to the show that puts you at the
center of the national conversation
talking about the issues that matter to
you the most
tonight it's all kicking off at the most
politically charged World Cup we've ever
seen FIFA claimed that the tournament in
Qatar welcomes all
but that isn't how it seems to women who
say their rights are curtailed or to gay
people whose very existence is illegal
in that country
most fans say that football can change
the world look at the kick it out
campaign
and if Harry Kane and Gareth Bale can't
even choose what armbands to wear just
how seriously should we take that claim
I'm Trevor Phillips and this is the
great debate
[Applause]
thank you
each week we get to the heart of the
issue dominating the headlines is it
possible to separate football from
politics
Qatar wants this world cup to be a
celebration of the most popular sport on
Earth but there's more than a game at
stake here FIFA has refused to allow
European captains to show their support
for the lgbtq plus Community without
being booked the fa whose slogan is for
all seems powerless to act and tonight
it looked as though the passion for the
beautiful game won't be enough to make
the finger pointing fade away
and tonight as ever a viewers panel will
have their say their share their stories
while joining us in the studio this week
are
the comedian Simon brodkin who some may
know better as a character Lee Nelson
professor of media and Communications at
Qatar University nuradin maladi
senior researcher of the women's rights
division of Human Rights Watch rothma
begum
and from Zurich the former FIFA director
of communications Guido tonioni
the big question tonight is the Qatar
World Cup an own goal for football
[Music]
we have our cultural neurons we are not
going to change the society for four
weeks even
the place continue to speak out in Qatar
I don't think we'll stop doing that in
fact we won't stop doing that
FIFA child World Cup teams to keep
politics and lectures on morality out of
the tournament
these are the players for tournaments in
Qatar and the players go there and play
the game the decision was made by other
people and if you want to criticize
anybody then criticize the people who
made the decision
today I feel disabled
today I feel a migrant worker
well as always we'll start with our
viewers panel and let's go first to
Muhammad Ahmed in Moss Side Manchester
Muhammad
hi um so I have an issue with the
singling out of Qatar as if we didn't
have you know South Africa Brazil and
Russia as the three other hosts it seems
bigger in human rights are all always
issues but only when really attached to
a Middle East country is there this
increased digital outrage
so you don't contest that there is an
issue here but you think that Qatar is
known worse than anywhere else
not necessarily but that there are other
countries that have also had issues
where we haven't necessarily had the
same level Outreach Russia is to me the
prime example of that
okay let's talk to shamina akhtar
um
shamina in East London I think shamina
what's your view about this
so as a young woman who really enjoys
playing the sport I'm disappointed that
FIFA has allowed cultural politics to
get in the way of unifying audiences to
enjoy a stream of competitive games that
would have helped people come together
football to me is a competitive Sport
and it should not be involved in global
politics in any way shape or form it
defeats the purpose of it being a sport
um the fact that it's managed to spark
this much controversy and debate shows
that due diligence just wasn't showcased
by FIFA Executives and picking our host
country that would not be subject to
this much Western face criticism okay
all right shamina you've got a question
for our planner but before you decide
what position do you play when you play
football
so football's a game you can play in all
positions I usually play strike but you
know it's a team sport I also play the
defense goal and Midfield okay so what's
your question
so my question to the panel is should
FIFA be reformed
okay that is a pretty Direct on the nose
question for today from shumina
does FIFA need to be reformed to change
the rules
it's good evening everybody
I think fee fresh needs to be reformed
since quite a while
but not specifically because because we
have now some problems in in Qatar but
FIFA had since modern football took
place and modern football starts started
with television and with the big money
in from the sponsors since then we have
some problems if the problem of
corruption and we have also the problem
of will be in a political political
pressure being involved in in football
what is very hard to stop but FIFA is
not enough aware of it FIFA always tells
foosball had nothing to do with sports
political politics have nothing to do
with sports and with football but that
obviously is not true
but do you think it is actually actually
possible Guido I mean uh the World Cup
will make FIFA what six billion dollars
I gather and isn't the problem here the
money
yes the money is one problem but uh let
me say one thing why should also always
a sport be this the top of of the
protests in in some countries uh we know
since 2010 that Qatar is the host of the
FIFA World Cup we know since then that
there are some problems which I do not
want to quantify now but since then
hundreds or or even more International
companies are making big business in
Qatar and nobody is caring about the
Labor's labor laws nobody is caring
about housing of the labels nobody is
carrying up the wage of of the wages for
the wages of the the workers and now all
of a sudden we have the culmination that
everybody is hitting Qatar because they
are not taking care of Human Rights and
other things look at the neighboring
states look for example at Iran Iran
today would need much more support for
the women's and Qatar the life of women
in Qatar is 100 times better than the
life of women in Iran and this is
something I would like to bring into the
discussion thank you Guido
nuradim
FIFA reformable needs to be reformed
well thank you for the invite and
um I'd like to express first of all the
the appreciation of the great job that
FIFA has done during the last 12 years
with regard to investigating loss of the
concerns that were directed to Qatar
since the winning debate in in 2012. I
think I think following the the course
in my opinion there were lots of
concerns raised with regard to women
with regard to uh workers force in Qatar
with regard to lots of other issues now
I understand that all of these in my
opinion were kind of Thoroughly
investigated by Visa FIFA let alone
other International organizations like
the international labor organization for
instance Qatar government also have been
a kind of appreciating all of these
concerns and they took them very very
seriously and in my opinion they managed
to take all the boxes which FIFA raised
which International organizations raise
which humanized organizations like for
instance amnesty and humans have also
had during the last 10 years so so so in
my opinion both FIFA and the Qatar
government should be uploaded for
reaching where we are now and yesterday
was a great opening for the World Cup
okay events uh Simon Brockton you um I
mean I don't want to belittle your
overall career but you became very
famous for uh as it were a stunt you
pulled showering stepladder at the FIFA
president with money
um how do you respond to what uh
noradin's just said
um
with shock
uh I think we do need to fix FIFA so
FIFA can stop fixing football
um and yes I did prank uh sep
um we've both worked with set geeto I'd
like my notes back I don't know if you
know where they went I showered him with
banknotes it was in character as my
Premier League footballer Jason Bent and
he was uh giving sep a uh the money the
bribe for the World Cup in uh that was
going to be in North Korea in 2026 which
was not convicted of any offense we just
need to say yes the irony was I got
arrested and he didn't which is uh
amazing but
um I I think
um that FIFA are
um a laughing stock
um not just because of the prank I
pulled but of course they allowed
themselves the atmosphere in which to be
laughed at set blat himself recently
said it was a mistake to give it to
Qatar
um they gave the bid to I think it was
in 2012 when they gave gave two World
Cup
um bid results
and it was Russia and Qatar and if that
doesn't make them not fit for purpose I
don't know what does yeah that was 2010
but points made let's just go back to
our viewers panel uh for a moment and
talk to Jamie Mclennan who's in Inver
Gordon in Scotland Jamie what do you
make of this
well clearly FIFA doesn't give a hoot
about any issues associated with Qatar
even though their laws and way of life
have long been known and documented
before being awarded this role and since
it's being awarded then even if a small
percentage of the media reports are
accurate then countries should boycott
all people events with the Sheep until
this issue can be addressed
okay thank you very much Jamie stay
there
um ruthner you must be pleased about all
the conversation going across the Glo
going on across the globe about human
rights what do you think about this
issue the the boycott
well we don't take a position on
boycotts that's a very personal and
political decision for people to take
but what we are calling on people to do
is to support a fund for remedy what
we've had is since 2010 when FIFA
awarded the World Cup to qazard they did
it without any due diligence on human
rights without any conditions on human
rights either which meant that even
though they knew that there's going to
take millions of Migrant workers to
build the necessary infrastructure to
deliver that World Cup they didn't do
anything about ensuring the worker
protections for them and as we suspected
huge amounts of abuses took place
including widespread charging of workers
illegal recruitment fees then forcing
them to live in terrible forms of
accommodation working in extreme heat
and humidity and then stealing their
wages a lot of workers had their wages
stolen over the last 12 years and many
of these workers also died thousands of
them died in uninvestigated
circumstances and now
there's a very different picture from
the rather glowing one you painted well
rotner I think this is an exact duration
I don't think the Qatari government from
the beginning they said we are
infallible or we don't have issues to um
of concern to to to to address I think
they they've raised them with the FIFA
with other International organizations
as I mentioned I mean very clearly with
the international labor organization and
the statistics are available on their
website and there is lots of stuff by
the way I I would like to point you to
that the the Qatari government during
the last 10 years I think they did do
excellent job with regard to addressing
these issues I mean one of them for
example is raising the wages
without everything related to the rights
of the workers I mean I can tell you
that I worked on Qatar long before they
got the World Cup right so before 2010 I
was documenting migrant work abuses I
knew what the situation was FIFA would
have known what the situation was but
they gained the World Cup anyway and all
of those concerns they were addressed
and they were raised they were raised
and they were addressed as of Saturday
as on Saturday
in the cave of the World Cup workers are
still facing abuse I think all of them
agree uh Guido where do you stand on
this do you think that qataris actually
did respond to the complaints that were
made or not
I think that age I think they did and I
spoke recently with a tough trade
unionist or in Switzerland she was there
several times and she denied that she
was against all these allegations she
was there on the on the working places
and she was there in the in the housing
place and so on and she said there is a
significant progress there is not yet we
have not an ideal world yet in Qatar
Visa workers but she says that in the
last years since she was visiting year
by year the the place that the Qatar
made significant progress in the in
regarding the labor right and payment
and and and taking care of the of the
workers and the housing too all right
thank you greeter look um let's go back
to our viewers panel you have heard some
of the points that have been made I'm
sure you have all watched the news and
you've been reading the newspapers the
big test today actually was
whether the European captains would wear
the armband particularly on the issue of
LG uh B T Q Plus rights I'm going to put
this to you
uh it was decided by the Football
Association that Harry Kane would not
wear uh the uh armband that he wanted to
because it might attract a yellow card
and risk his participation further
I want to ask you do you think that
irrespective of that Harry Kane and of
course Gareth Bale should have worn the
rainbow armband those who think they
should have just gone ahead and worn the
armband anyway please put your hands up
a significant majority of you would
think say that he should have worn the
armband
well I think we will pass that on to our
colleagues over in sport
we're gonna go to the break you're
watching the great debate
up next is the criticism of Qatar
nothing more than Western hypocrisy
England and Wales captains will not wear
one love armbands their World Cup
matches in Castle Harry Kane and Gareth
Bale could have been booked for
breaching the equipment Rules by wearing
these unsanctioned armbands some of the
Iranian players didn't sing in their
national anthem and there's also some
jeering of the anthem
[Applause]
the contacts for example for advertisers
have now left the company so you have
several large brands that are wondering
what to do who to contact uh you now
have copyright infringements uh where
because Twitter has violated uh a U.S
law that restricts how much of content
you're allowed to upload uh they're not
policing that and you're having people
upload full movies uh in two minute
increments uh via their Twitter accounts
you have people continuing to uh abuse
uh footballers uh that and those tweets
are not being policed and taken down at
all in a timely manner you have on top
of that the Blue Tick Fiasco where musk
launched this commercial idea that you
would charge people eight dollars per
month to keep a Blue Tick which is
basically a verification tool or an
attempt to do that and you had companies
that have or people who have
impersonated companies uh also buying a
Blue Tick so for example Eli Lilly the
pharmaceutical company that makes
insulin is one of the market Leaders
with a bogus tweet from a bogus account
saying we're now giving insulin away for
free so it's an absolute uh disaster in
terms of what's going on inside this
business and also users are leaving you
know that's the most important thing
Tick Tock is picking up the slack
Mastodon an alternative sort of uh
platform for chat and is is also
learning that they're gaining huge
numbers so the defections the staff
layoffs the impersonations the online
abuse I mean frankly this really is a
brand in in a lot of trouble
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
welcome back to the great debate where
we're asking is the Qatar World Cup an
own goal for football
now there's been a debate raging ever
since Qatar was awarded the World Cup in
2010 with a population of under 3
million no serious football history no
infrastructure and soaring temperatures
many believed it should never have been
considered yet there are plenty of other
places in the world that Outlaw
homosexuality and repress women in the
eyes of the West so is it fair to single
out Qatar when many of the countries
competing in the World Cup could also
justly be criticized for laws we may
dislike
um let's talk to ikra nawab who is
herself a football fan the Iqra what do
you think about this point
um being an avid football fan tells
about car you know yours is always an
exciting one but how I see it is that
the World Cup is being overly
politicized and it's turning into a way
to nitpick at Qatari culture and the
country's religious practices it would
be a different story if they were
disrespectful or slandered the lgbtq
plus Community but this hasn't
explicitly has happened so my question
to Pano is isn't it hypocrisy to claim
the moral High Ground
thank you
um you stay there Acres question for the
panel is is it hypocrisy to claim the
moral High Ground neurodim yes it is I
mean certainly it's very hypocritical
what has been going on for the last few
years with regard to
um a kind of sending signs of lessons
from above to the to the qataries as I
mentioned before and I'd like to direct
my speech to my colleagues rotner and
also um Simon to come and visit Qatar
come and see Qatar for yourself and you
and you can see what I'm talking about
and also what um uh other people who are
trying to paint a different picture from
what we see in some of the media reports
Qatar has made huge strides with regard
to improving human rights the workers
rights addressing all the issues that
were raised in the beginning since it it
won it won the bid
um Qatar never mentioned that it is a
Angel's country a country full of angels
every country is not infallible so
therefore I mean what I'm doing Simon
um yeah you've just been offered a first
class ticket and hotel
um
in in Doha are you going to take up that
um invitation let's talk travel
Arrangements after the show
um I mean you I am I living on a
different planet here to what's going on
using the term nitpicking about what's
going on Qatar I think you said all the
allegations have been looked at and
dealt with and you're talking about
um Guido these huge strides it is
illegal
to be gay right and FIFA your former
organization awarded the most
prestigious prize in the whole world of
football
to a country that is clearly woefully
short of the standards that we now hold
oh I don't represent anyone I'm not here
for Britain and I'm not here and and
this throwing stuff going you guys did
this then and that's why should we allow
you to speak I'm not trying to lecture
anyone I'm not trying to say anyone's
better than anyone and of course
European history is blood soaked and
completely in many aspects wrong but
that doesn't avoid the fact that right
now going on in Qatar today and they've
just been awarded the World Cup you are
imprisoned or sometimes I believe killed
for being gay and women's rights are
unquestionably
um woefully sure
and the and the final thing which is
clearly again the workers if qatar's got
billions and billions to spend on the
world why could it only give the workers
pennies an hour
uh yeah you've been there
do you recognize picture Simon's
painting
no I I basically agree with Simon I
agree with Simon that this is the wrong
place I I don't agree with Simon that
Qatar is the only place where the gay
people and others have have problems to
to live speak about Russia speak about
other countries but Qatar is too small
to host the World Cup I told this to the
Qatari already in the year 2004 when
they asked me can can we I was working
there they asked me can we have the
World Cup I said no you can host Olympic
Games in October by the way today the
temperature is not a problem for the
athletes but you can host the Olympic
Games in October they were twice beating
for Olympic Games they didn't get it the
bait was were reading once we said okay
with this fifth executive committee
nobody read the technical report and
they got it you know it's not so much
that qatar's behavior and its
performance on human rights it's just
not big enough to hold the football uh
do you think that's right Roth now is
that the reason that it shouldn't have
been in Qatar from your point of view
they should have done due diligence on
human rights and they should have set
labor rights conditions it's one thing
to give it to them but then to set no
conditions whatsoever when they knew
millions of Migrant workers were going
to be needed for that infrastructure I
mean this is a country that didn't have
a big enough airport they didn't have
public transport miles of roads all of
that has been built eight new stadiums
we have now all of that everything in
sight that you see in Qatar that fans
will see from their drivers to
everything you see has been built and
serviced and delivered by migrant
workers on low wages many of them didn't
get their wages and even with reform
then I do want to take this point
reforms were important but it took so
long we fought so hard for that in 2020
some of the most major reforms came two
years ago that means the vast majority
did not get to benefit we have workers
who were sent home humiliated without
their wages and this is pity wages I
mean you get 200 a month how much are
other people are earning right and now
you know we've got people who died
families who are suffering right now
because their loved ones died and they
got no compensation very big hopefully
because I want to talk to a couple of uh
audience members who've actually lived
in Qatar how do you respond to this
thousands or probably tens of thousands
of homosexuals and then people of
different cultural background different
kind of tastes and whatever are now in
Qatar the Qatari government has
expressed this many many times everyone
is welcome but we need respect of the
local culture if you are in Rome if you
are in Rome behave as the Romans do if
you are in Rome Simon behave As Romans
do what they are asking is simple
respect of the local culture and
everybody in the world when you enter
their homes you you you you you are
asked to show something you don't get
you don't get killed or you don't get in
prisoners
this is the exaggerated Simon and it's
untrue all right
very very briefly we're not this debate
is about where the Qatar should have got
the World Cup I'm not interested right
now in looking at the uh Qatar and how
nice your life is out there of course
you're not a worker building the stadium
you are not a gay man yourself you are
not a woman and these are the people
we're talking about who are so sorry
I want to go back to uh I want to go
back to our audience and talk to our um
viewers panel and in fact there are two
people
um who in fact grew up in Qatar let's
talk first to Sarah little what do you
make of this debate about Qatar and what
it's like really
yeah well I spent my early Adolescence
in Qatar and while there have been
strides towards gender equality over the
past decade there is certainly a very
long way to go Qatar is the only country
in the Disney today that continues to
enforce male guardianship laws for
females Travelers under 25 after Saudi
Arabia lifted those in 2019 wives are
required by law to obey their husbands
and can face legal consequences if they
don't cultural women don't have
authority over their children's finances
their travel documents their official
documents and sometimes they're
schooling and Medical Treatments not to
mention there's little opportunity for
women or girls to actually play football
in Qatar so I think that while it's
great Cutler is the first Arab and
Muslim Nation to host the World Cup it's
unfortunate that it comes at the cost of
accountability for upholding women's
rights all right let's um stay with us
and let's talk to uh Lauren um
Lauren Armstrong I think Lauren you're
in Bristol and you if I understand it
rightly grew up in Qatar
do you recognize the picture that that's
being painted here
well I'd like I'd love to understand why
Qatar and this event in particular have
attracted such negativity GCC countries
and with similar laws have been holding
international events like Formula One
boxing golf tennis and MotoGP for many
years and have not experienced so much
criticism
celebrities are often seen holidaying in
the gulf and many many Global pop stars
have performed there so why so why Qatar
why Qatar is receiving this and why this
event in particular
okay let's go let's go back to our panel
and uh
rothner
waikato of all I mean you could have
picked all sorts of other places
complain about human rights we do we
pick every country and We complain about
human rights in fact we're complaining
about the UK We complain about Bahrain
and the F1 that's being played there We
complain about golf being played in
Saudi Arabia we talk about all of these
countries and their human rights we
could end up with a situation where you
can't have sport anywhere because
everybody's got a problem it's not
talking about we don't talk about
boycotts we're not saying boycott these
places but we are talking about
sometimes does it make sense to have it
there and if you're going to have it
there what does it mean so in a country
like Qatar they knew it was going to
take millions of Migrant workers to
build the infrastructure and they didn't
do anything when we talk about women's
rights what did they do in the last 12
years honestly if you look at the
reforms the biggest reforms came 20
years ago they've in fact fell behind
they are an outlier when it comes to
women's rights in the region they are
far more repressive in women than many
countries in their neighboring states
all right we were going to come back and
talk more about that in a moment you're
watching the great debate up next
it's begun so is it now time just to
kick back and enjoy the World Cup just
focus on what's happening on the field
and not off it we'll hear from the
former England manager big Sam allardyce
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the great debate where
we're asking is the Qatar World Cup an
own goal for football
well what are those inside the game
think about the World Cup taking place
in Qatar Sam allardyce has managed
England and several other Top Flight
teams he's been giving me his views
about the criticism of the tournament
Sam thanks for joining us um what did
you make of the whole issue with the
armband and all of that
well they feel it necessary I think that
um whatever we feel or what we'll
discuss on England discuss in terms of
whether they wear the armbands or not
once that decision is made then um
that's a very positive thing you know we
all know that people are talking about
human rights still
um and we have to hopefully not let that
take over the football in the end what
what role do you think footballers
should be playing in that whole issue of
course there was a question of whether
hurricane should wear this and this
armband and so on do you think that it's
right for footballers to get involved at
that level
personally politically no
I think that they're politically
football should stay separate from
politics
um bring in politics into footballers
considered to be to be extremely
extremely dangerous you know so uh
um that for me
it's not quite the done thing but of
course if there's a collective uh view
in terms of the fa uh going forward and
the players agree to it I hope that none
of the players have have uh flagged up
any differences that they may have had I
don't think they haven't and they and
they go along with it you know and
they've taken the knee I don't think
anybody else is are they
uh not as far as we know this moment but
when you say it's extremely dangerous
what did you mean
well
politics in football is very dangerous
in terms of what you what you involve it
in and what it can disrupt what is our
game our national game and shouldn't
really be a part of it for me it should
be purely about the football we I think
we talked about the the human right side
so long before it I don't think we
should talk about it when the tournament
is going on let me put the argument
that's made on against what you've just
said which is that actually
some gesture from the England football
team even though we gave them a tonking
might well have lifted the Iranian women
who are protesting against what's
happening in their country
well yes I mean it it can be a platform
for everybody to voice their opinion I
get I get that but as in terms of what's
happening around with the women I am not
I'm not I'm a football manager not a
qualified or a deep person in terms of
look at it to actually comment one way
or the other players have been taking a
knee for two years uh today Harry Kane
has I guess been instructed by the fa
not to wear a particular armband because
of course he might have be got himself a
yellow card next thing we know he's out
of the game I suppose one criticism that
might be made here is that the players
were prepared to protest when there was
no cost to them but where it might have
risked the game they actually decided
not to follow principle what do you make
of that
no that's a players our CFA
not the players I mean the players may
look at that situation in that so but
the fa would not jeopardize
their participation in the World Cup I
would think
if they're that strongly or feel that
strongly about it you know that they
should uh remnestrate or make their
points clear before the players get
involved for me so uh obviously I don't
know the ins and outs of it but
obviously it seems that FIFA have said
they can't wear those arm buns and and
that as as obviously got them to choose
not to not to do that
lastly Sam
um what do you make us FIFA's Behavior
through this whole Saga
well I am at the moment watching the
documentary on FIFA of course and of
course uh one would Hope they've cleaned
the laptop are packed up enormously
compared to the documentary that I was
watched
um
the sad thing is after all that
investigation and after all that uh
interrogation if you like and all that
weight it doesn't appear that anybody's
really been punished enough
um and that's a a great sadness but
let's hope it's triggered the fa into
running their and their
company their world of football
governing body in the correct and and
obvious manner I'm not going to let it
get interrupted or or corrupted by money
Sam thank you very much indeed
perhaps now that the football itself has
started Qatar will become a world cup on
the TV just like any other these big
events are when a nation tends to show
its best face to the rest of the world
and the rest of the world conveniently
forgets its shortcomings
so now the games have begun will the
noise outside the stadium just fade into
a distant chart let's talk to Amy ladoe
in um with them
Whitton I beg your pardon
um what's your view about where we are
[Music]
um people should be feeling excited
um to be able to watch the World Cup in
winter time especially with all the
economic issues that we're having to
deal with
um I don't think that discussing these
issues will make a big difference it
will just be casting a shadow over
people enjoying a game of football so my
question is why don't we focus on the
football
okay thank you very much uh Amy there's
quite a lot of
uh there's some thumbs down I think
there's a lot of reaction anyway uh
Amy's question for the panel can we just
focus on the football uh Guido
can't you separate sports sports and
politics I don't think so I don't think
so that we can focus only on football
would be nice but it's not the reality
uh you asked before if this is an own
goal of uh of Qatar and FIFA it could be
a known goal but it's premature to
already make a decision you have to see
what happens in the next 55 matches or
60 matches and then you can make a final
decision but what I would like to say is
that Qatar probably today as it is today
that would not again beat for a World
Cup in their country
but greater are you saying that if the
football's great fun and there's drama
and there's really great football we'll
forget all the stuff that for example
Rothman has been talking about
the drama will come we will have enough
drama in the next few few weeks you know
but I think that especially the media
that we still put the finger on the on
the problems and good news is no news in
media in the media world you know and
they cannot stop from one day to the
other what they have built up in the
recent weeks they missed a lot of
opportunities in the last 12 years but
now they they go to a climax I think
this will be a spoiled World Cup uh
whatever happens on the field it will be
spoiled by by the by the side side noise
which will appear day by day and we
punished the organizers and FIFA Rothman
this is an interesting point that
actually the world will be very excited
about some of the issues you've raised
today but by next week when all the
dramas on the field and who's gonna
reach The Knockout stages and so on
it'll all be old news Well I want people
to think
of bands around this world you may be
sitting at home wanting to join football
right or so are the kids in Nepal and
Bangladesh and India all of these kids
are massive football fans they play
football in their pictures their parents
love football their parents were
involved in building the stadiums and
the roads that allowed these fans to go
and enjoy these games but some of their
parents never got their wages they died
and football for them is bringing up
mixed emotions they're really happy they
want to celebrate these games but it's
so torn up by what's going on and FIFA
made a crucial mistake on the eve of the
World Cup all they needed to do was to
say that they would remedy the abuses of
the last 12 years they have seven
billion dollars they're going to make in
Revenue they have the money why are they
not coming in with remedy all right look
um let's let's just pursue this issue of
you like the emotional
pool of football and whether it can
overcome some of the arguments we've
been talking about and I want to talk to
Judy Fay because I know Julie you are a
big supporter of um the Wales team
um yes I am is there anything that could
persuade you not to watch Gareth Bale if
they get through the group stage and
into knockout
I should be watching the Welsh team of
course I will
um but I will not be watching the World
Cup as a whole like I would normally
when the World Cup comes on
um I watch pretty much every single
match and I love it but
this time round it's different
I've watched football all my life my
father Trevor was a captain of the local
football team
my nephew is a professional coach and my
daughter plays for her University team
and as you say I'm also Welsh I promised
myself that if ever Wales got to the
finals I'd be there
however my daughter is gay and I love
her more than I love football
so I won't be going given the human
rights record of the coast country's
regime
FIFA is an organization where corruption
hides in plain sight and yet the game
brings joy and inspiration to Millions
how long are we going to put up with
this
how how long is this going to go on is
the Qatar World Cup going to be one step
too far
there's a lot of support for that point
of view on our panel there Julie thank
you uh Nadine do you get the point here
that actually
this has spoiled the game for some
people who love the game
um Let me let me talk about the um I
know sponsor that I mean the the the
Qatar government for the last 12 years
has been employing hundreds of thousands
of unskilled workers from around the
world from the poorer countries who are
who were stopped from having any
opportunity in the Western countries
Qatar has been employed people from
Bangladesh from India from Nepal and so
forth and all of those people as I
mentioned in the last 10 years all of
the issues raised by human rights
organizations and including FIFA they
were sorted out
hang on you've made this point in
several ways I want you just to deal
with Julie's point that she adores
football she loves her team yes but what
she understands about Tata even having
heard what you said yes three or four
times already so you don't need to
repeat it yes it still makes it
impossible for her to want to watch the
World Cup do you understand that I think
I think the world today and yesterday
has been in seeing a world-class event
being organized by Qatar with the FIFA
right what has been achieved should be
uploaded in my opinion as a world-class
cultural Festival world-class football
festival and it should be looked at this
way now this is one okay secondly I hope
I hope the whole people around the world
approach I mean appreciate that this
small country Qatar there to put a bid
in 2012 and win it against the us
against Britain against other European
countries okay okay you've taken
uploaded for that you have taken us to
an important point which is about the
money and we're going to talk about that
in a moment you're watching the great
debate coming up what will qatar's World
Cup Legacy be shouldn't human rights be
in the starting lineup for any future
bids
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
here
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
the roads have been inundated the only
way out is to get people by boat
this on any given day would have been
bustling with people but today it's
absolutely deserted I never Lazarus and
I'm Skye's reporter based in Delhi
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the great debate where
we're asking is the Qatar World Cup an
own goal for football well what Legacy
will Qatar 2022 leave Johnny Infantino
president of FIFA talked rather vividly
of unity peace and Global togetherness
the other day perhaps he hopes that the
issues discussed will shine a light into
some dark places that wouldn't otherwise
have been mentioned
and should we expect Those Behind These
Global events to be more honest about
the power sport holds in the world I
want to talk to
Maria cash about this who's in our
viewers panel Maria
what do you make of it
so when it comes to the advertising
companies
um it's business yes but I think there
I've got the opportunity to raise
awareness and Shine the Light on issues
um like players speak up and become
advocates for Charities and raising
awareness
um I think the advertisers have the
opportunity now
um to a worldwide stage to do the same
so my question to the panel is
what can future World Cups take from
this one
okay thank you so much Maria that's a
positive um look there Maria's question
for the panel is what can future World
Cups learn from this one Simon
um
there's some upsides here aren't there
well the world now knows more about the
abuses of Human Rights and about various
people's rights in Qatar I don't think
that's a good enough reason to give it
to Qatar look FIFA aren't going to
change they're happy they're driving
around the shoulder driven cars going to
their big hotels they're they're happy
qatar's got what they wanted they're
happy money wins and it is just Grace
has gone to Qatar but it was also
disgrace it went to Russia and that the
Olympics the Winter Olympics went to
China yes but just because we're making
a noise about this and not enough about
other things it doesn't mean we should
be quiet about this and there's a lot of
what about Arie going on what about
there what about there
yes let's make more noise about
everything
um and and
um you know it's uh it what can we learn
we can learn hopefully that that FIFA
isn't fit to be awarding these things
Meridian just very briefly
do you don't feel that there is some
sense here that money has really swept
all before it we don't have to defend
Qatar but just generally as a matter of
principle
I mean I mean money is very important um
uh tool and provision to to to make
international Global events like this
successful and without having a enough
funding for this event's money uh Qatar
would wouldn't have been Qatar Qatar
have so far as officially announced has
spent about 200 billion dollars in
infrastructure to the new its
infrastructure as a country but also to
be to be to be to build they have been
paying a lot
so much money okay they've been
employing pay them more yeah
I mean I mean five seconds as of
yesterday FIFA very very clearly in the
opening ceremony announced that there is
no disgrace as mentioned by my friend
about Qatar on the on the contrary
they've been talking about strides big
strides of success and the event of
awards are extended
breaking the Monopoly no Dean I have to
stop very briefly
um people who say money's one here what
do you think
money is one is the key issue but you
asked before is FIFA learning the lesson
I think they learned the lesson and if
they do not learn the lesson then FIFA
is a hopeless case and keep it keep in
mind that this time in Qatar the
national associations start to raise
their voices what they never did before
before it was FIFA was much more a
dictatorship now that right the
awareness of the of the power of single
National associations has grown and I
think that it cannot be repeated what
happened in Qatar okay rotner very
briefly this is a world cup of money and
privilege a ton of people made money out
of it but not everyone the low paid
migrant workers have missed out and we
were talking about a legacy because
every World Cup has to have a legacy
that Legacy should mean that workers who
face wage that get remedied it's old
wages people who died should be
compensated and when we talk about
eligibility in women they do need to
ensure that they're improving on these
situations which they're not right now
okay thank you very much all because
that's all we have time for this evening
it just remains for me to say thank you
to our panelists here in the studio
Simon Brockton noradin maladi Rothman
begum and Guido tonioni
of course it's you at home who are
always at the center of our conversation
if you'd like to be part of the program
next time get in touch by emailing the
great debate at Sky dot UK and for now I
want to thank our viewers panel who has
always contributed and really set us a
light tonight actually I really
appreciate it
we'll see you soon
um and of course to you at home thank
you for joining us this evening keep
talking
and we'll see you again with another big
Topic at the same time next week for the
great debate
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]